war zone kings one-minute time control
war zone rated once again 50 players so
far average rating 1815 time handicapped
30 minute tournament any experience
level can enter none no criteria on that
here we go
three two one another tournament let's
go oh the big bad wolf I think you
resigned last time he was a resigner
French win or it's a queen gonna get
trapped she might get trapped
oh she ran scared she was scared here we
go I'm launching it it's being launched
it's launched here it is fishing go fish
I'm still playing here what am i doing
oh I can't castle oh oh I got the Queen
there we go okay alright alright alright
this is a resignation isn't it time to
resign um support my knight in plays
five there we go that's delay can drop
that pond that's okay I have this this
is gonna be a killer discovery killer
discoveries check rook check mate soon
move the bishop and then mate on g6 get
the other book over there
clear the way my queen wants to play
clear the way the Queen wants to play
the King is running a stop running away
there we go here we go
f7 right come on this is a resigned time
on the bishop back to tournament two two
two two a bunch of ones ex got X Man X
to the future
I really don't want to capture if that
happens let's do this we're trying to
focus on these dark squares uh-oh uh-oh
Johnny pawn center Johnny pawns I'm
gonna take that
what's this like a crazy reverse Benko
gambit what is that what's going on with
that okay the center is crumbling Wow
I'm getting beat up no I was just ready
to castle with my clean getting pushed
Oh getting crunched crunch time oh there
was pawn push right there that would
have been lethal I'm on the rookie
castle before it's too late night right
here hit the rook and the pond I'm there
but I really don't want to capture it
giving checks maybe I should have
captured it bishop right here and then
to f2
over here I want to play g6 think thinks
it should be pretty good I'm still gonna
do it I could get myself into a pin I
think I'll do know my bishops hit my
rook is pinned
let's hit the rook I want to get this
pawn before it's too late okay get out
of that pin get out of that pin right
now oh crap okay I gotta go with this
gotta take the Queen and then this oh
that's a slick move
good move good move good move I have
time advantage though just push and then
hear them on C to hit this Knight pigs
pigs pigs pigs pigs everywhere pigs pigs
pigs oh these guys are really hungry
hungry pigs kill the bishop kill the
bishop mate in three threat one two
three back to tournament six six five -
lets go 26 minutes left a lot of time a
lot of time to change positions 20 now
how do we get okay here we go
okay more of this bishop battle f7 let's
see if I catch them in pre move pre
moved they were kind of pre move kill
the rope
develop hit the queen castle first hit
the queen next now what pawn push and
then get him these light squares or
something
pins on the rook I want to advance my
past pun
let's take here and then play my queen
out I want to get rid of that dark
square Bishop let's go here watch over
this oh this is falling but no I could
just double its double chase that night
away next get the knight out of there
and then I want to I want to control
this square so that's why I didn't
capture first so now I'm ready to push
my bishops in a strong spot that was a
case of chasing my bishop to square
probably are you want to go to push push
again and then trade Queens okay
actually let's do this the knight right
here I'm just gonna take can't deal with
that guy should maybe just boxed it out
so now if light square for my king I
guess do what next let me go over in
this direction there there in a giant
knot let's go with these ponds they
can't move if the Queen moves they're
dead now let's get on the light squares
let's go here I'm gonna back my Bishop
up and then get to the light squares
back my queen up next oh they're being
sneaky very good I got the clean now
that's me very very close to it okay
this is all right they had no time back
determine 12:12 12/12
and okay an 11 massive pond 24 and
change okay still neck and neck a lot of
people up there with a dozen let's go
here all right
okay Center I go with this actually I'm
not gonna throw that extra pond up there
it's not needed okay is it gonna be
capture no no capture just yeah that
rook move is not good it's not a good
idea to do that because that file is not
gonna open up it's gonna be this one
over here maybe I should do this to stop
knight h4 ideas let's back up kick this
night away soon okay dark square
weaknesses I want to trade dark square
Bishop sand get a knight right here get
a Knight to c3 after the dark square
bishop scum off okay here we go
or this square this is a killer I'm on
the Queen connected passed pawn I'm not
gonna do that I don't want this push to
be getting in connect to pass pawn soon
I'm gonna do this in my bishop could
take up residence on that beast be three
square although there is oh it was
missed there was rook to be four in that
position
resignation resignation Queen takes here
next let's defend okay I'm on my own
let's trade I'm on f2 at the end of this
f2 f2 f2 still with my queen can't be
stopped unless they're a sack of rook
resignation or not 22 okay back to
tournament twenty twenty twenty of still
a bunch of 20s right here alright let's
go let's go let's go let's go double the
points and
let's do this let's get in as the bishop
gonna defend no it's not okay I might
want to push the knight is if it plays
there whoo okay pawn push coming up not
so fast my bishop was hit right there
and I'll hit the bishop good get a
center stop the knight from coming here
f4 next I have a centered pawn push and
then I get the h7 h7 is on get that each
7th pawn check let's come back here the
knight could maybe be a pain let's stop
it and then Knight to f3 everything is
coordinated let me switch roles here
with my queen and Bishop let's back up
and let's grab this pond and get here
next Forks Queen out to h5 it's a fork
there's no rush with that I'm on the
bishop Queen here take the bishop okay
let's check and then am i doing the
bishop moves then I have me I think I
would have me aah
oh that's a good move I got to give that
up
can I get the Queen how much time I
don't have any time oh I messed that one
up
wow they're killing me rook no no no I
should have gotten the Queen oh they're
out of the they're out of it check and I
could take take the night with check are
not with the check but um if the Queen
blocks yeah I take the knight with the
check okay right here right here with
the rook all right let's try this I have
a have a material edge okay I'm on this
okay time burners just make sure this go
quick go quick check
right here down check takes look up
flying
you check coming up back to tournament
they're down a time forty two thirty how
do you have 4200 if you have six games
in oh that one should have finished a
lot sooner I miscalculated right there I
had um an overwhelming position I
thought okay let's go let's go you know
what's coming here it is still gonna do
it it's still gonna do it I want that
file open okay let's go for it now let's
go for it
okay okay okay okay
pawn push oh man I gotta take the bishop
with the check and then recapture the
knight is gonna kill me this is not a
good idea
oh man this is bad news bad news bad
news bad news oh it's bad news for me oh
man what's happening oh it's scary it's
very very scary run King oh I want to
cry it's very scary over here oh there's
a check I'm dead I'm a dead man
oh I have nothing can I get the rook oh
I'm B resign oh I shouldn't have given
that up that was too much can I come
back from this stopped right in my
tracks no you will not have any of your
fishing poles they say no fishing poles
for you no go fish for you go somewhere
else
you and your night crawlers go elsewhere
all right let's go check no no no no no
cuz now it's inconvenient for that dark
square Bishop oh this is tough to
overcome right now
no awake is it possible is it a possible
one come on at forks forks forks forks
actually I'm just gonna grab that pun
I got the fork get the Queen next got
the rookie rooks rooks rooks I'm gonna
take my bishop and then the knight
uh-oh I had a killer fork right there
that would have been TKO ah man
ah man that would have been best right
there I get another check this is still
beat I mean look it I have I have a full
rook time is good too I just don't want
any time to take off my clock I'm just
gonna pretty move stuff pretty moves
Primo's and then pre moves pre moves
anything more Primo's more Primo's
pre-move double check check check
I don't want any time to burn off my
clock let's go back to tournament 4000
56 56 42 42 40 40 come on you could
fight back
don't give up hope don't you dare start
giving up hope right here ah yeah that
was pushing it right there when I didn't
win that f4 move is in there okay mental
know if that F pond if there yeah that
pond is on f4 you might want to think
twice about casting your line there okay
but it's on here it's on here so far Oh
take them take them take them okay
oh I didn't want to do that I didn't
want to do that I want to cry
let's come here we can take my night now
and still can't you still can't take it
let's do this okay let's do it now type
of it didn't I learn my lesson didn't I
learn my lesson from the last game when
I took a beating and a half oh I gotta
go into a prevent prevent mode get rid
of that night what a pain
oh he's a pain he's a giant pain that
night let's come over here right here's
where I want to be okay I got a run run
over here King right here I'm in
checking distance oh oh oh oh I've
thinking about my queen this is gonna be
bad how much time do I have I'm losing
again no you can't lose again tricky
Knights tricky Knights defense tricky
Knights tricky Knights oh it's very
scary they're trying to get rid of my
knight I'll have none of it hit the
Queen they're very scared pigs pigs pigs
everywhere there we go g2 it's better
work if it doesn't work I'm dead I'm a
dead man
okay Oh get back here pigs pigs pigs
just in time pigs to Queens but verts
with two queens versus two pigs doesn't
win back the tournament those pigs were
hungry they got the King they were
Hungry Hungry Hippos here we go oh it's
just the guy last two because I gave up
my night when I shouldn't have open
Sicilian okay so what do we have here
Queen Queen Queen to b6 no okay
Yugoslavia TAC Yugoslav attack it's very
scary over here pawn push pawn push what
are we gonna have it's a little scary b4
yes b4 is there you better be able to
defend defend like a champion c'mon
LightSquared bishop defend okay this is
scary time scary time right here going
on I think II five would be good Oh
man I'm in trouble I am in a place
called trouble oh man Wow
oh I have this as a defense my bishops
there but my bishops gonna be dead now
queen defend do something check I got a
run on my king defend defend defend
defend come on hang tight you can do it
you could do it
run King pack up and run you have no
home over there you're homeless stop
this stop this defend defend defend hit
the Queen just for fun and then come
back time burner that's a classic time
burner right there oh look jump in this
bond
oh come on King over here Queen over
here Ron King run over here you could do
it run faster come over here they're
ready to be sneaky you could defend
defend defense defense
over here no I dropped a pond they
missed it
I got this guy over here push my pond I
got the Queen kill this guy check how
much time they have they have no time no
time check time burners time burner time
burner everywhere time burner time
burner time burner Paget oh there we are
70 110 110 90 80 I have 70 how much time
11 minutes and change let's go here
let's go let's go let's go let's go
fishing
Go Fish get the Queen get the Queen here
we go it's being launched it's being
launched let's try it anyhow I'm not
sure if it's working just castle
actually it's not working I yeah let's
do this wait if each three I had to
react oh I should have taken the pond
let me throw in a check and then let's
get over here oh I should just take that
[ __ ] up he's stupid
just take that bishop I don't mean my
opponent stupid I mean the bishop is
because it's not doing anything
here we go b5 the palm push I have a
nice square that was probably my
opponent probably misfired with that one
that was a mouse slip oh oh what am i
doing my light square bishop wants to
play play f7 ok queenside castle or
something
my queen wants to get to the dark
squares dark squares dark squares dark
squares okay is everything all right
what do we got Bishop here that night he
needs to go hit the Queen and then get
to d6
oh they got this pawn but then I got the
rook let's break it open break it open
oh that's a killer check that would have
been a killer check I can't get run here
now Oh support that pond okay oh man may
I have may h2 there it is h2 everybody
loves h2 8888 i'm counting backwards
here 130 is the top guy 11 out of 11 Oh
10 minutes and change let's go here oh
let's go come on all right I've space
everybody loves space what are you gonna
do with your space advantage now put it
to use do something with your space g4s
may be a bit crazy I want to hang on to
my LightScribe Bishop he's a good guy he
is an important guy to hang on to let's
get back here keep the knight on the
edge let's come over here get rid of
this guy he's tough he's a tough guy
over here okay let's I guess support
stuff he needs to go let's go f5 g6
I think I'll do this anyhow just break
open stuff give me the dark square
Bishop upon push let's just do it I got
to break it open okay get to e5 I'm on
the night as well Knight to e5 Knight to
e5 actually Knight to c6 forks I'm on
this as well I should have taken there
maybe I'm on I'm on the rook oh I had
the Queen I don't want to trade Queens
now the Knights guarding that then
that's check actually okay
the bishop might block though it's not
blocking I can actually do man okay I
have this or do i I don't the Knights
gonna block okay I got a double up
double up okay I have this double up how
much time though how much time how much
time how much time removes Primos
premium premium go go go go go go how
much time
okay back to term it went away 150 how
do you catch 150 140 128 any of those I
need the confetti oh this guy he's the
one of the leaders uh hope he's having a
strong tournament b5 it's taking forever
for me to move with my mouse can I get
this in oh I should have just played
there it looks a little weird I'm gonna
do it get that night out of there
capture this way dark squares I have
this pond I'm gonna give a check first
and then come here this is a he's the
glue this guy is uh gluing everything
together my LightSquared bishop there
might have been a sac right there
I could double up right here it's gonna
be captured let's just hang on to it
come is this crazy is this crazy doing
this with my King might be crazy come on
you could do a king be a fighting piece
the King is a fighting piece Reuben fine
or he's an attacking piece somebody said
that oh-oh-oh-oh
rook up and over that's a killer my
Kings gonna have to run for the hills
right now he's gonna have to run for the
hills do I have enough support I gotta
go with my beep on uh-oh if you can't
break this down there's nothing
Oh my Kings gonna have to run wild he's
gonna have to flee I got the rook what's
happening oh wait I got to take this and
then go run pine run pond oh come on
defend defend defend
let's go here my rook is defended there
Ron King just don't get mated just take
care or something okay run run run run
run and over here it's safe over here
buddy it's safe over here I'm on the
Queen it's safe over here take the Queen
checks come over here defend here here
run he's really fast how much time no
time they're back
okay back to Terran I took out one of
the top guys one of the top guys but
there's many others oh I didn't want to
do this okay I want an a4 okay Bishop b2
and then f4 kind of delayed Birds
opening or something you get this in
clean here or maybe that's not even
needed let's go a knight here first I
have to watch out for ìiî ìiî here we go
tempo for coming up pawn push followed
by a fork is the threat here we go I got
it material game pawn push again got the
piece Knight right here is maybe the
best resistance but I think after the
knight grabs here I have Queen to e5
hitting the knight and g7 night here
Bishop takes Knight takes pawn Queen to
e5 hitting g7 in the knight on f4 come
on is this a clock burner five minutes
and change before this tournaments over
G file now what there might be Queen out
here in some variations but I have the G
file my king could always run away I
might have that right now and similar
thing knight on f4 this is what I was
talking about around the knight and me
then I can't go here I have it the Queen
right here might be the best defense
actually I take the knight I get my
bishop taken
there's no time though no time for my
opponent maybe take the Queen pawn takes
give a check the knight would have to
block otherwise its mate Bishop takes F
less than ten o'clock burner this was a
fairly quick one if they're just gonna
let the clock run out
that's main quicker back to chairman 148
190 190 ah man I have to look for third
158 can I overtake 158
that's maybe still doable four minutes
and change those guys up there in the
top I'm having a fantastic tournament
maybe I should pinpoint f - B - and f -
mate mate threat if the bishop takes my
knight it's leading to me this is close
to me I got the night of the night right
this is close to me really really close
to mate right here
killer mate that's me this is what I
needed
back to tournament once 168 once 60s 210
now 2/10 193 minutes and change top
three can I get top three confetti is
what it's all about that first place
confetti is what everybody is after in
these tournaments who cares about the
qubits when there is confetti okay
Bishop b5 Castle quick look for the
jugular go for the jugular where is the
jugular give a check first and then
recapture okay and to take here and then
take here and then hit the Queen a
little bit and then get to f5 with my
night killer fork killer fork is it
gonna be allowed okay discoveries
discoveries discoveries here the Queen
has to go into the unto this file right
here and I think I want to do okay get
the Queen away deflect the Queen away
from the defense of the bishop looking
for me somehow against the king like I
look up an over type of thing
smashed through on each seven with check
this is and now bishop here move the
knight g7 is hit the Queen is close to
being trapped actually right here is and
it's trapped she's trapped right now
she's cooked less than ten nine eight
actually I'm just gonna do this just I
don't want any time to go off of my
clock
three two one no time no time back to
tournament 188 232 2188 188 I'm battling
with that guy
top three gopher come on two minutes
this is maybe the last one here we go
can I get this castle come on h 2 h 2 h
2 h 2 matin - it's not a matin - i'm on
f2 though let's go where's the main
right here I'm on the Queen this is
resigned time come on you know you want
to resign grab that Bishop pins pawn
push give a check come on it's a making
one making one come on this is B this is
way beat rook mate lock this is me back
to chairman how much time one twenty two
come on
208 208 220 one minute 19 1 18 17 16 15
14 let's go pair me up with anybody
somebody anybody
I need to play to win go go I don't want
to that's what a wonderful start yes
resignation back to tournament - 28 to
30 come on one minute left
come on come on come on come on can I
get first - 28 - 28 the assassin come on
if I'm winning against the assassin is
the assassin in a resign I think he does
if I'm in the lead materialize let's go
44 seconds come on just take that let's
do this and then and then what
I don't even know what I'm doing bishop
here I can't do that I'm not gonna be
able to get that on the Queen I'm gonna
throw an in-betweener I'll just resign
come on you're down to Brooke
15 seconds 15 seconds I'm on the Queen I
didn't mean to do that to Mel slip mouse
lips I'm on the Queen I'm on the Queen
again back rank mates five seconds
Oh what I get what I get what I get what
I get what I get third Oh
third place confetti oh man even if I
won that one that guy ended up with two
5002 52:28 a tie for second but they
gave me the third ah man
good games I was lucky to even get in
the third place right there
good games off